I don't know I'm a mess doesn't help  that I'm an introvert any introverts  here all right you guys rarely speak up  yeah not fun being an introvert no one  gets us that was in an uber once the  guys like so you're nicked your bird  talked about that I'm like well it's not  really how it works yeah it's tough it's  hard to be around people all the time  day jobs and how you guys do it 9:00 to  5:00 eight hours of this group then five  o'clock rolls around some guy goes hey  we should all get drinks what are you  insane you wanna hang out more we're  done we did it we're outside the walls  let's go home yeah we like being alone  we do you ever got to eat with the guys  like hey look at that dude it's him by  himself you're like I know living the  dream